Some cute and cuddly guests.
An unexpected onscreen attack.
Keanu Reeves' first showbiz job
is a world away from "John Wick."
It's always fascinating to see the entertainment
exploits of big movie stars from before they were
famous. There's Steve McQueen in "The Blob," a
low-budget horror movie that has almost nothing to
do with the kinds of films McQueen would become
known for later in his career. Many who know
Leonardo DiCaprio from his collaborations
with Martin Scorsese might be shocked to
see him as part of the cast of family sitcom
"Growing Pains" in the early 90s. Of course,
Marylin Monroe was famously a pinup
girl before she broke into films,
and there are several former child actors who have
managed to eclipse their young brushes with fame,
such as Kurt Russell, who appeared opposite Elvis
Presley in "It Happened at the World's Fair."
When it comes to surprising early
roles, one of the most charming
examples comes from the career of Keanu
Reeves. He's best known as the steely
assassin John Wick and the messianic Neo
in "The Matrix," but once upon a time,
he was just another young person trying to make it
in the competitive world of Canadian broadcasting.
Back in 1984, a good five years before his
breakthrough in "Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure," Reeves hadn't done any
real acting to speak of. The "Point
Break" star's first showbiz job was as a
correspondent on the Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation's "Going Great," a youth-focused
news magazine program. One of his more unusual
assignments on the program has become
the stuff of pre-fame movie star lore.
Years before "Bill & Ted's Bogus Journey," Keanu
Reeves was just another correspondent on "Going
Great." His most memorable assignment
saw him covering the inaugural Canadian
International Teddy Bear Convention, an event
that attracted serious teddy bear collectors
from across the country and possibly the world.
As Reeves himself said during the assignment,
"When I was sent to check out the first
Canadian International Teddy Bear Convention,
I thought I was in for a lot of craziness."
Reeves continued,
Luckily for fans of the future movie star, Reeves'
assignment covering the Canadian International
Teddy Bear Convention has made its way on to
YouTube. Many viewers have already noted that
Reeves seemingly displays a hint of Ted Logan,
his character in the "Bill & Ted" franchise,
in his approach to human interest TV news.
The "Destination Wedding" star manages to
show an unbridled enthusiasm for the strange
world of teddy bear collecting. Basically,
his report is a great reflection of
the open-heartedness he is known for
when he's not killing rival assassins or rogue
agents in his most famous feature film roles.
"Why are all the bear's first name Teddy?"
Of course, the violence of "John Wick" and
"The Matrix" isn't completely missing from
Reeves' early brush with stardom. In
what has to be the video's highlight,
Reeves performs a great gag where he pretends
to be attacked by one ostensibly friendly fluffy
teddy bear. In this hilarious clip, he shows
an inkling of the incredible onscreen fighter
he would one day become. Obviously, the moment
is also a great showcase of his sense of humor.
"I've been looking all over for you."
If you're a Reeves superfan, it's unlikely
that his "Going Great" coverage of the 1984
Canadian International Teddy Bear Convention
will replace "The Matrix" or "My Own Private
Idaho" in your personal Keanu Canon. However,
it undoubtedly provides an invaluable glimpse
at the screen performer in his early days, and
may even be more entertaining than "47 Ronin."